why it crossed over to such a good way I
think it was just the storytelling
involved there is a genuine mystery in
the case of get out you really don't
know where it's going the audience knows
okay there's something weird about this
family but exactly what you don't know
but now you're really watching because
now you're watching a mystery in the
case of get out you felt you were in
good hands Jordan Peele knows exactly
what he's doing one of the most exciting
moments in a movie theater is when you
feel them watching the movie to such a
degree like really paying attention to
it and then something is revealed the
picture isn't fully done but now the
outline of the barn and the landscape is
starting to come into effect and that is
the moment when he goes through the old
photos what I mean when it comes to that
moment that you're waiting for That's so
exciting is when the audience does a
collective
oh and you have that moment happen you
have that moment happen and get out